boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don shotgun
very excited to still be at KO fest the
Congress on the future of engineering
software for our second annual
partnership with them we are now
speaking to joe walsh hello hello thanks
for coming on to the show well thank you
very much having me this is gonna be a
lot of fun very excited
Joe's background is crazy interesting he
spent nine and a half years and still is
the CEO and founder of insurance 'm
which is developing next-gen engineering
applications shorter development cycles
and leveraging innovative technologies
he has also spent four years and still
now is the CEO and co-founder of assess
initiative which is bringing together
key players in software tools for
model-based analysis simulation and
systems engineering to expand use and
benefit of these tools Joe before we get
into that which is going to be super
exciting I want to ask you about your
journey how did you get to the point
where you're at today where did the
fascination for engineering software
come from tell us about this journey
okay actually my journeys very
unorthodox I started out as an engineer
as studying engineering architectural
engineering in school with a specialty
in structural analysis then I was
actually acting as a structural engineer
for about 8 to 10 years and more and
more that developed into understanding
how to use finite element analysis how
to use numerical techniques to do the
analysis and to do the structural
engineering and then one day I basically
woke up from that environment and I was
irritated with the company I was working
for because I got the height the best
rating ever and they're gonna give me
the same raise who is the guy who did
terrible and an opportunity came along
to become a applications engineer for a
systems integrator so it was an
interesting opportunity I jumped at it
partially because of previous
frustration but partially was something
new and different was talking to people
and I was a rare engineer that I was
good at talking to people so I decided
to jump on it and then I was going to
learn sales I was going to be in a sales
environment doing the technical support
quickly the CEOs idea of selling was
going out to the golf course and waiting
for customers issue
so I forget out if I needed a job I
better figure out how to do sales so I
picked up a book by Zig Ziglar and
taught myself how to do sales then
shortly left that company and started my
own consulting company working on very
complex engineering problems that people
would having trouble solving and in then
I was actually invited to head up for a
UK based company and North American
entry of their finite element products
and then a year afterwards the CEO
called me in and said I'm going back to
the UK why don't you take over as CEO so
I got to be a CEO of a two million
dollar a year software company at the
age of 30 so it was very interesting
very dynamic and two weeks later I was
sued by our shareholders we immediately
had a major cashflow problem had to let
go eight people so it was a whole
experience in baptism by fire yeah
and spent three years doing that turned
the company around got it working well
and then moved on to another uk-based
company in setup operations there and
brought their product to the North
American market so as a matter of
understanding the technology the
application and having to learn
marketing sales accounting financials
all in order to make it works I couldn't
hire haven't afford an accountant
anymore so I had to learn all these
principles all these concepts went back
to my own consulting company where I
decided I was gonna do go back to being
an engineer and then I said so I went to
all the major companies and said give me
your near impossible problems that the
big guys can't solve and that I almost
starved to death for three years and
then it turned out that Goodyear and
NASA called me on some problems that
we've got something they won't solve
Goodyear had a great one says we've been
working on it for 18 months we're
willing to give you a try bad news did
you get six weeks we've had an army of
10 people working on it for 18 months
and we haven't Mabel do anything you get
six weeks and so we went ahead and did
the project it took seven weeks and at
the end of the project they called me
into their finance department and said
you can't leave without signing a
retainer for the next three years we
don't know what you're gonna work on but
you're gonna work on these
so that then led to working on
interesting projects for very different
country companies but the company's
technology he was based on decided to
sell itself itself I could see the
writing on the wall and so I applied to
be to work for a friend of mine who I
knew ran an ad in a paper for someone to
read in southeast sales for component
software for Asus solid modeling so I
called so I called up and said you want
to save a headhunters fee yield he
called me immediately with it he had the
plane ticket in my hands and told me I
was hired when I got there so I took
over sales for spatial - it was the
first time I've ever done just sales
I've been part of what I did so I
learned okay how in my wife yelled at me
why are you trying to sales or an
engineer and I said I want to find out
what I can do so we actually led and
built the best sales track for the next
three years
and then I went on to head up the became
worldwide VP of worldwide sales for iron
CAD and then VP of business development
for eight years for symmetric doing
automatic mesh generation technology and
then founded in trance and the key thing
on the the component software technology
from spatial in from symmetric so what
had taught me was we had to deal with
hundreds and hundreds of different
business models every customer and the
component software model had a different
business model so therefore was learning
how to adapt the business models and
that really taught me an understanding
about where technology and business lie
and how they cross into each other and
how business people rarely understand
technology and technology people rarely
understand business so that was the the
reason for founding and rinse them in
the first place and although as you
mentioned we do engineering applications
and things intrinsic owns 0 IP hmm zero
intellectual property we do have a
technology broker model or we actually
broker technology to other software
vendors and we manage the licensing
which took a real estate broker we don't
own the house we don't own the IP we do
it all with other people's intellectual
property
and that then led to okay we met enough
people and we saw things happening that
the assess initiative made sense to try
to see we saw some opportunities where
there the entire having coming from the
simulation space we saw that the
although growth was occurring there was
a huge opportunity because engineering
simulation can actually drive Hugh the
major business objectives
and it wasn't being utilized but people
beginning to realize it and we realized
that engineering simulation isn't it is
only growing eight nine percent a year
which is four times as fast as any other
engineering software but we feel felt
they could grow significantly I'm being
facetious by only eight to nine percent
a year this is for over thirty years and
so the the idea was that we could really
build that there really was an
opportunity for an inflection point for
dramatic growth of that entire industry
and so I decided to that it was too big
for any single player too big for the
big software vendors too big for the
end-users so I created the assess
initiative as a consortium to bring
together the people to enable that
significant growth yeah this is such a
cool story so going back to when you're
finding yourself at like using and
getting used to from an art from an
architectural perspective getting
involved in the engineering process and
then seeing sort of that you are can
also pick up as an engineer business
skills and sales skills and then you had
multiple sort of examples of times that
you amesh the technology and the
business side of things together and
were able to that's a very very
important skill the super important in
this there's a lot of talk and you know
in Silicon Valley and other places in
the world where you see that you know
maybe coders and sales people just are
you know kind of on different
wavelengths and stuff like that but I
think it's very important to be able to
find that that that overlap and how to
make sales relatable to technologists
how to make technology even more
relatable to sales and business so
that's a thing that you mentioned I
think
extremely important to embody and that
really adds that multidisciplinary
perspective of when you know how to you
know build rapport with humans as well
as know how to program a computer these
are very interesting things to to know
how to do both of and then actually with
you know going all the way up to to
insurance them even before that you
obviously have had a tremendous amount
of experience it doesn't I don't even
know what is this like thirty-five year
or something already forty years of
experience yeah so that's when that's
when you really know that you've you
know you're not even at you know you're
at like 2x or 3x mastery level in a
field and that's that's really important
and then to continue this this this very
humble Prince this humble first
principle as you continue going is just
gonna you know ramp things up even
further down the line but I don't rinse
him what you just mentioned there let's
start with this where you said that your
and I want to back up prior to insurance
in which you you were explaining how you
know you don't own any IP but the it
almost acts like a platform that yet
people bring on their services to and
then you license out those services but
maybe before even before that which I'm
sure you're gonna correct me and
everything but before that teach us
about you know give us give us a little
bit more on those like 20 years of time
especially those last you said there
were two periods where you were VP as
well a to like meta your organization
what was going on there it was a little
bit it's a very eclectic background
there's a very opportunity driven and it
was very much listening to the passion
and the challenge and learning to grow
and it was constantly about oh there's a
whole new role let's let's figure out
how to apply engineering analytical
principles to the new role so of
applying the approach you would do to a
very complex engineering analysis
problem actually turned out to make
accounting very straightforward and easy
applying that to sales actually turned
out to be very very effective and you
think of sales instead is a very highly
nonlinear problem but within
non-linearity is the people's
personalities
so it's totally unpredictable so it
becomes there is actually a class of
engineering problems that you solved it
or that sort of thing so applying those
same principles to sigh countless
applying engineering principles to
psychology to the sales processes the
things was actually very challenging and
very interesting and it was very and I
said opportunity driven very eclectic
and constantly a learning experience and
so it was all driven by the desire to
keep learning and and so everything was
a new experience including legal things
some of the things you learn aren't
wonderful you learn and and every
experience teaches and in that whole
process there wasn't a here's my five
year goal here's my ten year goal it was
I'm gonna get through today and and
learn something from it and tomorrow
we're gonna grow from that and in
following the vectors at the point in
time that made them accept most sense
when when you speak about taking
engineering principles and bringing them
into psychology that is such an
interesting field that we've you know
we've talked about on the show quite a
bit is how can you potentially even map
out human experience you know you know
in an engineering mindset type of way
can you what our computational
properties of consciousness these types
of thought processes so okay so now
let's now take us to you know all you
know this this little this last thing
that you're mentioning about engineering
simulation and the importance of that
I'm very excited to talk about that but
as you as you find yourself doing
intrinsic and you're learning on both
the you know business as well as the
techno technology side of things you
were mentioning there's different these
different really cool use cases across
businesses that you're kind of working
and building rapport with them seeing
what they need giving them the right
tools and solutions to teach us about
what that's been right ok well insurance
in was an experiment or still is an
experiment and the experiment is on the
idea that this eclectic background that
I had that actually took me into the
different areas so it took me into the
marketing into the sales into the
business into the finance into the legal
as well as saying in the technical and
it also so my experience also that had
me connected up with all the technical
people talking about all these issues
all
the time so at intrinsic I came to the
realization that there was a break in
general between business and technology
people would have great business models
needed technology they needed to feed
the beast people had great technology
couldn't figure out how to take it to
market so it created entrancing under
the principle of connecting worldwide
business and technology and the idea is
it would be limited only to the
engineering software space we wouldn't
sell to anybody else only sell the
engineering software vendors but what we
would do is we would provide two
different sorts of aspect we would go
find some interesting leading-edge
technologies that they could license as
components that they get embed inside
their software okay this would be like a
an add-on to CAD no it would be like the
rendering engine in it in CAD it would
be like the solid modeling engine in the
CAD it would be like the finite element
mesh generation in the CAD it would be
so that the end-user would never see it
he'd never even see as an add-on its
core functionality but it wasn't
developed by the software vendor okay so
inside the yeah and embedded in in in
the AutoCAD interesting so and then your
and your friends that started that
company that went through you would get
paid and you would get a percentage of
that exactly interesting okay so so that
what we did is we set it up and said
okay we know technology people need to
go to market we know people who need
technology so we'll start there and we
made that connection so we reacted as a
broker acting between the connecting the
right people together and then we said
okay now that we have this part of the
business going now we're going to turn
on and say well actually there's several
other people who just need good business
consulting good marketing consulting
good positioning good messaging how do
they actually explain their market how
do they take their product to market and
so we started that thinking primarily
focusing in smaller and medium-sized
businesses the larger software vendors
found out about it and they didn't want
us to develop their strategies they
wanted us to vet their strategies so we
work with companies from like Autodesk
with companies like Siemens and we work
all the way down to the two million
people in the garage we don't there's no
difference we'll work on projects as big
as everything it takes to go to market
or as small as we need help
this presentation if we fill whatever
the gap is including building websites
whatever it takes and so we build the
very we have a very virtual company and
we build in we have resources we can
bring in the build in whatever needs to
be filled very small team that is core
and then we build out as we need to for
every project all the way to we're
actually working with another company
swing - all the way to sales and so it's
all about what are the gaps how do we
fill those in how do we make the people
more successful this thing I'm all in
engineering software all in engineering
software only so the idea was there we
couldn't have a broad space and a broad
offering yeah yeah so either needed to
have a broad space in a in a in a very
small narrow offering or we need to have
a narrow space and a broad offering yeah
so we went with the narrow space and a
broad offering very cool very cool so
then you ended up becoming the
one-stop-shop for engineering software
that's right then that's kind of what
now
and we've also because we do this with
so many people thing we're also the
one-stop-shop for well we don't know
exactly when you want to talk to someone
about manufacturing simulation yeah so
we're the connector the connector - yeah
yeah
okay well now this is so cool I'm a mix
I'm running all these ideas of what this
looks like you gave us an idea of what
one of the one of the ways that like a
CAD software company it would want to
license through you one of the cool the
additions that they'd embed into some of
the algorithms they didn't bed into
their CAD software and then the user
wouldn't even know wouldn't even know
and then then the that's one example
give us other interesting examples like
that from insurance okay so the one
example is that we have a portfolio of
about eight different technologies where
we use it would call a technology broker
model when we do the licensing or it's
all embedded inside no one sees it no
one just knows anything about it and was
that the majority would you say of the
of insurance in is doing stuff like that
it's actually about half and half right
now it's a little bit more than half
that's the slight majority is still
doing that technology licensing
the other half is go-to-market
consulting okay we're people we will sit
with them and have a brainstorm session
about where are you what are you trying
to accomplish where are you going what's
it take to get there and how can we help
you get there so this may include things
like we work with sayare and generative
design on trying to refine their message
in how they can better position against
the competition and how to create a
unique position that they can leverage
for go to market and awareness we loved
hosting them on the show either
incredible they are incredible yes and
we like working with them to help out
their technology but we work with
probably we we worked with over 60
companies on that aspect already so far
and so we work with anything we also and
we work with with companies for instance
to do complete awareness campaigns
social media campaigns press releases
collateral and basically whatever it
takes to fill that position so in one
side we're working with the the whole
idea of saying okay I've got good
technology I need to take it to market
and the other side I've got market I
need tech I need more technology to fill
within in the third interesting twist is
we're also working with larger companies
now on basically being the voice of
reason where they will bring in all
their people and explain the strategy
and why it's so wonderful and we'll tell
them this is great this is great here
you're drinking kool-aid that's nonsense
yeah and because we've been doing this
because we know everybody we can get
away with that oh yeah and there's
actually value to our calling them on
their stuff so so the last part would be
if they do have their technology and
their business kind of properly
structured then you would come in and
say that this parts great this part is
it needs help etc okay now with give us
a give us a because if the other 50%
almost is on helping engineering
software with their business strategies
give us an example of what that looks
like because you said the scales
anywhere from the full go to market all
the way to the deck right yeah well
we've been seeing happening more and
more often now is people basically have
really good technology they don't
understand the target markets they don't
understand who's going to buy it they
don't
saying how to message to those people
messaging and positioning are really key
they understand who the competition is
or or what the positioning is against
the competition so we help clarify all
that sort of information we help them it
could be we could stop there
or but more and more often it's becoming
we then help them make the collateral
whether it's the PowerPoint presentation
data sheets whatever is opposed whatever
is appropriate to convey that messaging
and we become very thematic and
consistent about that messaging and we
achievement teaching that idea of repeat
repeat repeat from marketing and let you
know for marketing what I want really
super and we repeat that again and so
that we really get that home to the
engineers where we're successful with
that is we can actually under when they
talk to us about their technology about
why they love it we actually have the
technology background that we can
understand their technology so they
trust us when we talk about what to do
with marketing that's right that's right
and so ways geek out to build rapport
exactly so we built that bridge between
the technology and classical marketing
and it's not wrapped doing anything on
marketing that any good marketing firm
would do it's just we get the guys over
here to believe us and then they can
communicate and we can communicate to
them and so all of a sudden we know how
to market their technical features yes
where might they might spend six months
trying to figure out how to explain that
to a classical marketing theme we'll get
it in an hour yeah that's great
correct correct give us give us an
example of how a technic engineering
software company is is maybe struggling
with the business side of things and
then how you come in and and have you
know you like you said the geek out the
friendly build rapport and then you can
really just you know synthesize into
making really concise and powerful
go-to-market statements and to get the
right clients yeah so we've got two
active cases we're working on right now
one is SIA or we're doing exactly that
and other is a company called PSR E
which is about piping research and they
do piping simulation software and they
do an exceptional job on that and we've
been working with them about right from
the beginning and how to grow markets
there and how to message it and how to
position it we actually went all the way
back and told them know your product
structures wrong
we need a whole new product structure
because this processor makes sense to
your engineers but not to any buyer so
that we go all the way back to defining
what should the product structure look
like what should the pricing look like
what should the structure look like how
do we're gonna sell this in different
parts of the world been building channel
agreements for resellers the whole nine
yards and then basically going ahead and
helping the messaging and right now
they're currently very successful in
building an international distribution
channel whoa yeah the everything from
the from how do you do reseller
agreements and international sales all
the way to how is the product structured
for for people to purchase
how does most engineering software get
purchased through enterprise clients
it's a mixture of things it depends on
the song the engineering software it can
be your buyers can be anywhere from a
few a consulting company to a large
enterprise company to depend on the
industry
AEC is a bunch of your selling to
architects and engineers there's a bunch
of small contractors so you'll get
subcontractors you basically have a
supply chain of major OEMs in the
automotive and aerospace industry with
something with multiple tiers of
suppliers so you sell the different
levels of supplier chain when you get to
industries where engineering software is
and there's mature it's more of your
selling to whoever's up who's whatever
willing to listen so that like if we're
looking at manufacturing and you're
looking at the major manufacturing
people usually it's people who can
invest in it it's they fall in the two
categories they're either you have
enough resources to invest or they're
really trying they're small and they're
really trying to be innovative and
create a niche by their being by their
innovations so therefore they leverage
the engineering software tools mm-hmm oh
my goodness okay so so you walk your
walk you're giving us these great
examples of both of engineering software
being very technically advanced but
needing assistance on the business side
or being interestingly enough
potentially business savvy but not
having the right technical back what
does that one look like
so in that case for instance we license
several different technologies to
companies where they turn around and say
okay we're we're we have a great
analysis software but it really can't
read in data from CATIA or from
SolidWorks really well so we'll provide
them the technology to read that from
the data kit or SolidWorks or they may
turn around and say oh we've got a
really good algorithm for solving but we
don't have a mesh generation tool so
we'll provide them the mesh generation
tool and so we provide a variety of
different tools that can fit inside and
it's a matter of they they find a
technology gap and they then go to the
partner saying it's not a core
technology it's not what really makes
them difference but it is a key
technology that they need to have and so
that becomes the market where we can
help them fill those key needs where
they don't do develop that instead
license and integrate yeah yeah license
and integrate and and in this way they
can fill their needs with what they may
not have known technically exists on an
engineering software side because you
act as a liaison that that's grants what
they need that seems to be a reoccurring
theme with what you know what you kind
of work your way into on the business
and tech side is being able to be that
that one-stop shop which is so cool so
okay what what with insurance and Plus
now assess initiative which you can
explain here in a moment what has been
the the overall the connecting points
because it kind of makes sense that
everything that you've been learning
with insurance and now you're you're
basically trying to take the best key
players from the deep to the engineering
software process and put it into the
initiative that is it's actually correct
so that my background as I said started
out with instructional analysis and
those sort of things and I've always
been although we've broadened out and
intrinsic to do all the engineering
simulation and the other jobs where I
was running sales and business
development it was any engineering
software the symmetric was simulation
still it was mesh generation so that my
passion and my heart and my experience
in background really is still
engineering simulation were
with everybody in the engineering
software space but engineering
simulation is is the sweet spot it's
also an area where we have extra unique
capabilities very few people who
understand that technology and
application at all can even talk
marketing never mind understand it and
so that that that that was a unique
situation and I said that actually I was
invited to give a presentation at a
conference by a friend of mine and I
asked him what he wanted me to give the
presentation on and he said whatever you
want so I gave it on that the role of
simulation was changing the engineering
simulation was changing it was really
changing because of becoming about
business drivers not about technology
drivers up until that time all example
snow not cloud no it's the idea for
engineering simulation up until that
time it was things like the cloud it was
things like generative design it was
things like automated mesh generation
all these things were driving broader
use ok now all of a sudden there was a
change and that change was because now
there were in the 2008-2009 timeframe
when we had the downturn in the economy
everyone wanted to know how to be more
competitive they won't understand how to
be more creative how to be more
innovative how to reduce cost how to
reduce risk and very quickly people said
the way you do that is understand your
product and process performance better
and how do you do that engineering
simulation so it became two steps away
from all of the major strategic
initiatives of every company in the
world and the executives are beginning
to realize that so I made the
presentation is about it's about
business drivers and that's going to
change the dynamic of how we do
engineering simulation and that we have
an opportunity in this realization to
actually change the world and in of the
city the at least the simulation world
which does then because of what
simulation does it will change the world
and I gave that presentation I did that
and the result was the person running
the session says we need a whole
Congress on that I agreed I grabbed Brad
Holtz and we decided to put it together
he made it happen and and then ever
since then the assess initiatives take
on its own
life and it really is now a very
passionate thing by hundreds of people
saying okay how do we really make
engineering simulation contribute more
benefit to the users more benefits but
also really change the dynamic in the
paradigm of how we do engineering and
how we do design so that we become
function driven design and performance
driven design rather than shape driven
design okay
alright here's here's this here's this
key so now now tell me if I'm if I if if
I'm getting this right so when you when
you when you start off with a a that
that that there's this you know we had
things like cloud and we had these other
we were china maybe we're trying to
maybe push algorithms in to all these
different sites the types of processes
when maybe what we needed to do was
actually look back and refine the
algorithms to make them more engineering
simulation capable so that then that
when they get broadly applied to the
world that they are more effective so
that when when you're like you were just
describing that there's this there's
this a desire for a really powerful
simulations to be able to find the best
fit for an for a function in the
engineering design and then when you
find that that can then go and live
really robustly in industry but what the
challenge is is it wasn't about the
algorithms the algorithms have been
developing for years quite nicely but
that it was a matter of pushing the
algorithms the challenges that there was
a poll to do more or as I describe it to
people the poll was so it's in the
process of coming because it executives
are becoming aware of it so the
challenge I put to the analysts is to
say okay don't tell me how you can do 10
times more analysis in the next three
years tell me how you gonna do 10,000
times more because that's what the
demands gonna that's what people are
gonna be asking for our own success says
wait a minute why don't we do this
everywhere but the challenge of doing it
everywhere
isn't about the algorithms well the
algorithms are about 95% complete
nothing's ever 100% complete the
challenge is that the level of expertise
required to use the algorithms well is
way too high to do good CFD analysis of
an automotive vehicle and understand the
drag you're typically talking a PhD plus
five years experience before he's
allowed to actually set up and run any
designs that would actually in any
simulations that would actually truly
influence designs we can't build that
type of person fast enough yeah yeah and
that's the realization is that we that
the level of expertise required to run
this super advanced technology is so
high we can't possibly ever have enough
so now we have to go a next stage and
not dumb down the technology so we tried
that 20 years ago we have to actually
make the technology smarter so that the
level of expertise that's required is
lower interesting yeah yeah I'm
following now which is why companies
like SCI art are aiming to make
generative design accessible to
collegiate well yes exactly
at the early stage design wear so they
can understand design concepts and in a
way that they don't really they need to
understand the engineering problem but
not the details of how the engineering
simulation works yeah yeah
in today's classical engineering
analysis world you can't do any real
analysis on anything other than the
basic toy problem unless you really
understand not only the physics the
problem that you need to know the
numerix about how everything works and
so it's the level required level of
expertise is too high to really
democratize and so we have to actually
can we have to find a way to embed
intelligence to make software smarter to
make it so that more people can use the
tools that have less expertise they're
so good engineers they're just not
specialized analysts yeah and so we need
to move this to a broader audience to
int make influence more decisions
interesting but the idea being so so one
of the
questions we ask is is if people say
well why do you want to do that you say
no no why why isn't it been stronger
first because why do you want to make
dumb design decisions this is about
making informed design decisions with
the physics performance understood with
each design decision yeah yeah it takes
some odd 35 years to mold the human that
can do what potentially what a
democratized engineering simulation
software can it can do that and then
this is so cool because then you can the
the the high demand of the exponential
technology hockey-stick
of all of the different robotics and
automation that are happening globally
is able to actually be fulfilled by
bringing down the level of expertise
that is required in order for engineers
even in at the collegiate level to be
able to to run these engineering
simulations at the same time I'm curious
to hear your thoughts it is it is it's
giving it's democratizing engineering
simulation capabilities and we're able
to explore more a funk funk ideal
functional fits in different areas which
is extremely important at the same time
isn't then the like a an organization's
that create the optimal engineering
softwares isn't it then just kind of
just maybe 20 30 a hundred however many
people are building this more of like a
black box technology are they then the
only ones that really then kind of
understand it know basically what
happens is it's impossible to capture
for all the general applications it's
impossible to capture all the variances
and nuances that have to go through so
it's more about they're building tools
where the expert users of today can
embed their knowledge for their team so
there's very specific company knowledge
is very specific industry knowledge so
this isn't this cannot be done by a
software vendor just
not saying oh we just do all these
decisions for you know it has to be
instead building a whole platform and a
whole approach that enables the people
to embed their own knowledge in their
own understanding of how they make
decisions okay okay so that then becomes
the experts role is to create this
platform of knowledge rather than
running day-to-day analysis yeah yeah
okay okay so then so then the users of
the engineering simulation are able to
embed their own examples of use cases
that they need and they're leveraging
this because then they they don't
necessarily need to know a lot of the is
it like partial differential equations
exactly ordinace is partial differential
equations and so that they don't so what
they're looking at is if you can take
the experts of today to leverage that
knowledge and embed it in a environment
where that knowledge isn't required
instead leveraged then they can allow
people with less expertise to run things
the challenges come in that we need to
still make sure that the analysis is
accurate enough we need to make sure
it's credible enough maybe we don't you
know garbage in garbage out is how do we
avoid the the garbage in garbage out
problem how do we make sure that it all
still works correctly how does it
support the digital twin initiatives how
does it actually go all the way from
systems engineering all the way down the
detailed engineering so we're actually
trying to do not trying to take the what
we've been doing in the past and embed
that knowledge and make it usable we're
trying to actually do what we want to do
in the future in a to totally new
different way yeah yeah yeah the this is
so cool the the democratization is is
now it almost it almost changes the the
way that we can teach new children that
are being birthed into the world about
how they can get involved in engineering
that they don't necessarily need to know
by hand all of the repetitive
mathematics that's correct and then that
makes it as long as they know the basic
of the mathematic what we should be in
in my opinion we should be teaching an
engineer
is not the mechanics to sit there and re
derive the equations over and over again
uncreated understand the principles of
the equations understand the concepts of
the fizzy need to understand physics
really well to do engineering you'd
understand math reason reasonably well
but you wanted but its concept driven
and it's the concepts and then the
application so you can determine the
application of those concepts you don't
want to be adding redefining and how two
plus two equals four over and over again
so we we need to get out of the building
blocks and engineering a much higher
than that
we still don't want to be deriving
partial differential equations over and
over again it's been done once you
understand the concept now how do you
describe the physics problem how do you
describe what you're really trying to
accomplish once you understand the
concepts we've gotten caught into a
stage where people believe that in order
to understand the concepts you needed to
be able to derive everything yeah that
is in my opinion is false it's all about
understanding the concepts of physics
the concepts of engineering and then
applying the creative side as you
mentioned to the designs thing
interesting so let's see if we can then
maybe make it as a visual as there is
there are principles of math and physics
to make engineers and then those Kant
conceptual understandings of engineering
from there is all about applying that
creatively to problems all of as a
problem-solving interesting okay cool
cool so then a lot of maybe like Khan
Academy and these democratized
educational tools for engineering should
really need to be focused on the
principles and then leveraging tools
like we're talking about that has
embedded intelligence to actually show
the implement the instantiation of those
principles yeah yeah interesting okay
that would be so cool too I wonder I
wonder if there are actual is is there
an actual then point like child great
they're already doing so much self
learning nowadays so is there a really
kind of like a superhighway to well of
what
well the stem initiative is trying to
work toward that superhighway and
actually
the the right initiative isn't the stem
initiative it's the steam initiative
correct yes in there as well for the
creative creative portion because
without the creativity you're not doing
engineering you're just doing math and
physics yeah um so that you need to have
the art in there for the creativity so
it's all of a steam which is going to
power things which is a good analogy but
it is it is all about that so that's
there but I think we're still struggling
on the how do we get the people who have
graduated with a bachelor's degree in
engineering how do we get them to do
really productive work on leveraging the
capabilities of engineering simulation
tools today because normally that person
doesn't even learn about engineering
simulation tools until they're getting a
PhD so it's we're even working at that
higher level on the the expertise gap
now the steam initiative is helping we
don't have the tools ready to actually
play put simulation into that yet we
want to but we're long we're still
trying to get it down to the bachelors
level degree and we're gonna keep
working it it has to be worked further
and further down yeah yeah oh wow it
would be so cool to see young young kids
under 10 years old applying assess
initiative well the robotics and the
FIRST Robotics is one of the areas they
do they love and they do a lot with
actually physics based simulation but
they're quasi physics and games but it's
a beginning so that someone can actually
say well if I did this how would it
behave yeah and they're developing that
understanding and so that is starting to
happen there's a lot of room for growth
there it's just beginning all that whole
steam initiative is actually very
embryonic the first robotic stuff is
very young it's all but but it is it
both of those are great directions
they're both great things to go in and
the earlier we can get people thinking
about problem-solving and understanding
principles of how things work the better
yeah
and I think getting it down younger and
younger is really in getting it actually
better understood by every age is really
about let's get out of the details let's
not learn by rote anymore let's not
learn how to do math that's not learn
how to do addition by doing 50
additional
let's learn how to do addition by
talking over the concept of how addition
works
repeatedly until the concepts understood
then we only need to do three problems
because either we got it or we didn't
yeah yeah yeah yeah the giving
real-world examples that drive
understanding of concepts and then and
then I love how you point to things like
FIRST Robotics we love them we've
mentored their for a while volunteered
there for a while and interviewed there
multiple times their leadership and and
there's nothing more profound at times
like this is just when you see 13 to 17
year old teams of just girls that win
the highest level awards at the
competition and you and then I think to
myself they can teach me so much that I
don't know about engineering like that
is awesome the other thing is about that
activity is look at the passion and
their events look at the passion and the
kids it's just amazing when they're
given this opportunity to learn they
just are all in yeah they really it
really gives them a whole new look on
life and they get an understanding of
problem solving which now all of a
sudden engineering isn't scary anymore
engineering isn't geeky engineering is
interesting yes correct yeah so is
assess initiative than democratizing
engineering simulations the assess
initiative is its vision is to
significantly increase the use and
benefit of engineering simulation yeah
democratization is actually one of we
found out in order to do that vision
that's actually a key pillar but it's
actually one of seven key pillars what
are the other six the the we have to
align the government in commercial and
research efforts because they're
thoroughly misaligned right now can you
explain to us well basically what
happens is the
the academic community in research for
new technologies is disconnected from
the commercial world and so they're
developing in some cases they're
developing there they're building
absolute magic in some cases they're
building things that were already been
deployed twenty years ago and in other
cases they're building things that is of
no interest to anybody and there's no
discussion and connect
I shouldn't say no there's a very little
discussion in connection to the
commercial world the government is got a
whole different set of nomenclature
terminology everything for the same
tools and they're also rebuilding things
that are also commercially available at
much higher prices and this is done all
the time taxpayer with taxpayer dollars
and other grants could be going to much
different they could be going to
advancing the technology rather than
rebuilding the same technology that's
been around for twenty years and this is
a frequently recurring issue in
government spending they will say no the
answer is yes now there's certain groups
like for instance we work with Sandia
National Labs they do some amazing
things on physics development they
actually work with us on licensing some
technologies they don't reinvent so
there's certain groups that are actually
leveraging very well but in general it's
very common that they're doing something
that's duplicate the big problem is each
or each major vector doesn't even
recognize that the other vector exists
and they don't talk to them so they're
all acting in isolation so one of the
themes is we can't have that
inefficiency anymore so we have to try
to bring those together and Jesus about
of course the other three it is but what
is the thing that brings those first
three together that's what we're
wrestling with we have to we're
wrestling with why would they want to
come together we know that the current
process of the being independent is
inefficient then we're wasting time
effort money on in every single vector
so could once extreme of that
potentially be how china has things yes
set up that is one extreme that's not
the extreme we're trying to recommend
but that is one extreme where it is
actually all one thing yeah that's
exactly right so they don't have that
communication problem however there's
associated problems okay
[Laughter]
okay and that's that's one extreme and
then I I want to know what the ideal is
I mean you said you're wrestling with
that and it does there's a lot of
perverse incentives as well in in the in
the science foundation of science and I
think those are we've done shows on that
too that we are really working on on
creating an incentive system that that
is that is completely redesigned in very
fascinating ways and you know like we
were like you were saying that a huge
principle of that is the democratization
to get more people involved but okay
teach us about the where did you have a
do you have somewhat of anything that
you can share about there so there are
examples of what we call good examples
of collaboration good examples of
alignment Goodyear has done some amazing
work with Sandia National Labs so as
Procter & Gamble done some good work
with Sandia National Labs as well as
with Lawrence Livermore National Labs
so there are spot cases which are
exceptionally good and we're actually
trying to build a compendium of these
cases to put up as assess and say here's
what good alignment should look like
good so we're in the process of building
that compendium of use cases of real
alignment right now
and then it's almost as though you could
take potentially some of the best
processes from that exact use cases and
then maybe make that as a that's a
gradual set but we have figured out that
the the one key common characteristic to
all them is a champion on each side yeah
that really wants to make the alignment
work yeah that's cool so it isn't one
side can't drive it it's got to be a
champion from both sides that actually
makes that working that's that's very
profound and that makes a lot of sense
the one champion on both sides from from
let go from a research perspective to an
industry burton's aside interesting
interesting so moving on from the align
theme the next theme is business
challenges and one of the key business
challenges is how
how do we get the engineers to
understand the business language how do
we get them to speak to the executives
in terms of business benefits but also
from the same standpoint it's kind of
like okay what is it understanding of
the real value proposition and what are
the business issues that are gonna be
caused by actually trying to use broader
how what are the real advantages what
does that enable and one of the key
things that comes up is there's going to
be cultural changes it's not just the
technology change so we're working on
that particular aspect there the third
one is about credibility and that's all
about hold it how do we actually
understand whether or not the analysis
that's been done is good enough for the
decision it's trying to be used for it
on the principle that every simulation
is done to support a decision that
either has been made or will be made
so is that simulation good enough for
that decision yeah yeah so and and that
becomes today that's not as big an issue
because it's the expert analyst running
things and they'll tend to make it
overly good enough because they're very
conservative people but when we
democratize it now all of a sudden this
becomes critical yeah yeah because we
can't rely on Bill just over killing it
by the way we can't afford Bill to
overkill it anymore
so then the next one is generative
design because generative design will
enable simulation driven design so that
the function that you want is actually
going to decide the design rather than
the geometry so one particular
interesting story I like to tell is
generative design opens up an
opportunity where I come from the new
light design a new widget and initially
I have a very small volume so I'm gonna
build this with additive manufacturing I
start to sell more and more of these
actually additive manufacturing is not
the most cost-effective manufacturing
method anymore
it might be an extrusion method I sell
more and more actually I might want to
do casting because I have a higher
set-up cost but my lower the cost per
part so now I'm cast I'm doing castings
I'm selling millions of the widgets
someone who bought the original way
it orders a replacement widget he gets
one its function will be exactly the
same it will fit in exactly the same
same shape it will connect the same way
it won't look at all like the original
part it will be a totally different
geometry and that's because it's
constantly been iterated on it's because
it's been reassuring process yeah yeah
which means it has different constraints
it's change of shape is is limited in
different ways but it also opens up
other opportunities oh sure sure so this
thing that was all stringy and had
threads going effectively that's
probably not a good shape if I'm doing
casting and so it'll be more consistent
in solid yeah and so that it's um so
that the parts will change but the
function won't
yeah yeah yeah interesting these these
pillars are really well thought out it
shows the 40 years of expertise so cool
another summary of the pillars look okay
so the summary the pillars would be the
alignment pillar and then we have to
have the business challenges we have the
credibility we have the democratization
issue we have the generative design
issue we have the integration from
systems level all the way down the
detailed subsystems level and then we
have the engineering simulation digital
twins and I've heard this term now but I
haven't learned it yet engineering
simulation digital twins right please
teach okay so there's been a lot of buzz
about digital twins and in there the
first thing we need to say is there's no
such thing as a digital twin there are
multiple digital twins and I won't get
into a definition of a digital even what
digital twins are because of the fact
that they're very case-specific there's
very different types of digital twins
for different purposes so what we did it
assessed as we said okay if we focus on
just those digital twins that are used
for engineering
emulation in other words capture the
physics performance and have the
qualities of an of a digital twin so
these are digital twins which
specifically do their computer physical
physics representations that tie to a
physical twin and actually communicate
information back and forth to that
physical twin but their sole purpose is
about the performance evaluation that is
an engineering simulation digital twin
there are other kinds of digital twins
but we said we're gonna focus on making
a clear clean definition of what that is
so people can get understand the
characteristics they can understand how
to implement it they can understand what
it means it's not vague anymore okay is
this is this a correct paraphrasing that
there's engineering simulation that is
running concurrently with an actual
physical part in the in the world and
it's constantly having a closed-loop
feedback with that part iterating on
that part making it better it doesn't
have to be running concurrently it can
be running on different time sinks and
it's not a constant feedback but there
is a feedback so there is information
coming from the sensors on the physical
device that may actually go to a systems
level engineering digital twin to say
actually I need to run these for
analysis okay those may be run and they
will give information back what they
think it should be compared to the
sensors and back and forth some of this
will be as tightly coupled as you
mentioned as a complete feedback
immediate some will be totally different
time scales where the simulation might
be run once every six months or once
every three months or once an anomaly
shows up in this in the sensory data so
that it's going to vary on every case
yeah well so okay this is one aspect of
likely many aspects of future technology
that is entering into the event and the
engineering software space okay that was
a really really strong conversation
around what what what is it happening
did we do we miss something that you
think is very
very critical to also mention now I
think we've covered the main thing the
only comment I'll make is the assess
initiative came about because I had this
eclectic background from various
different things which led me to start
the it's led me to start and transom to
fill the gap which showed that there was
an opportunity in the for the market
that do they even intrinsic couldn't
fill but it took a collaboration so each
revelation led to another revelation and
it was this combination of eclectic
understanding broader perspective I
would advise to anybody always find a
way to broaden your perspective and that
then led to saying okay there is this
opportunity where we can make a
difference and we chose to go after it I
have so so much in agreeance with how on
a very eclectic multidisciplinary
background can lead to where you're at
right now and that is such a crucial
gist
it's very important to pass along to
younger generations is to be able to
have a desire for eclectic backgrounds
multidisciplinary backgrounds because
they can do really powerful things can
be can be done when you can connect dots
in novel ways at the edge of fields
especially new sciences emerged so for
the the young kids I would say if you
don't know what you want to do find the
one that you dislike the most and try it
if you like it great if nothing else it
will expose you to the things that are
next to it you try those and you try
those and you it's the experience you're
not going to sit back and say I really
want to be an aerospace engineer because
you don't really know what and this
aerospace engineer does until you
actually start doing aerospace
engineering so yes okay so you're
passionate about our stress engineer and
go there but actually pay attention to
the other things that are next to it and
learn and broaden and if any aerospace
engineer who can think like an artist is
worth a lot more than an aerospace
engineer who could only think math and
so this broadening of perspectives and
including the the artistic perspective
the psychological perspective the
philosophical perspective these are key
to advancing anywhere because if you can
broaden your perspective you broaden not
only your knowledge your broaden the
ability to see where the answers are and
that is in many ways the future is being
able to pair together philosophers
artists with engineers and scientists
and the ones that can potentially even
drive some of the geopolitical oneness
discourse that we have yeah so this has
been so fascinating we are very grateful
that we got to sit down with you
and you had to God you got the chance to
teach us about so much cool pigs well
thank you for the time thank you thank
you for coming on the show such an honor
such a pleasure thanks everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode go and
talk to more people about engineering
simulations share it with your family
share it with your friends and share
with your coworkers let's get more
people talking about this also check out
the links below to both Joe's work also
check out the links below to Co Fez
Congress on the future of engineering
software and support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in go and
support them in your community support
them abroad like us as well our links
are below give us a support and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thank you for tuning in and we will
see you soon